[Musique]
le pen la france bonsoir trois
personnalités sont venues sur ce plateau
nous expliquer leur soutien jean marie
le pen
sid ahmed yahiaoui conseiller régional
d'île de france jean michel dubois chef
d'entreprise et rovio l'arbre ancien
député roger holeindre vous êtes l'un
des plus anciens compagnons de jean
marie le pen en effet membre fondateur
du front national avec jean marie le pen
à ses côtés depuis trente ans je peux
prétendre que je connais bien cet homme
c'est pourquoi moi vrai hollande qui fut
l'un des plus jeunes résistants de
france qui a été combattants
parachutistes en indochine et en algérie
aujourd'hui président du cercle national
des combattants je me permets
solennellement de vous appeler à voter
pour jean marie le pen ancien
d'indochine
vous ne pouvez permettre que l'histoire
de votre guerre que votre passé glorieux
soit falsifiée et sally laotiens
cambodgiens vietnamiens frères d'armes
vivant en france fait confiance au seul
candidat qui fut de tout temps vos côtés
un anticommuniste courageux anciens
d'algérie
ne laissez pas raconter vos combats de
façon honteuse et scandaleuse par des
individus qui sont les frères ou les
fils des porteurs de valises du fln
vous n'avez aucune raison de ne pas être
sûr d'avoir combattu glorieusement dans
une guerre où vous avez envoyé les
gouvernements socialistes de l'époque
vous devez refuser avec toute votre
énergie d'arrivée massive chez nous des
soi disant intellectuels du fln qui hier
là bas ont égorgé vos frères d'armes
dont les musulmans fidèles à la france
parmi lesquels 150 mille harkis qui
avaient cru à notre parole et qui ont
été assassinés décapité ébouillantez
jaulin mais le pen a été avec vous dans
le combat de l'algérie il est resté
fidèle aux musulmans français
exact c'est très exact anciens
combattants musulmans de l'armée
française
vous les rescapés du massacre perpétré
par le fn m sachez que seul jean marie
le pen vous rendre à votre dignité ainsi
qu'à vos enfants car la france que nous
voulons bâtir avec lui sera une france
fière et debout tel que vous l'aimiez
jadis jean marie le pen cet angle
j'ai pour la défense de la considération
due aux combattants pour la défense de
vos droits légitimes matériels et moraux
il est le seul homme politique de ce
pays à avoir en tant que député
rejoindre deux fois l'armée au combat il
est le seul à continuer aujourd'hui à se
battre pour que la carte du combattant
soit autre chose qu'un simplement son
carton sans valeur il est le seul à
demander la révision des dispositions
scandaleuses prises en 1959
concernant la cristallisation des
pensions dont était titulaire les
glorieux combattants originaires de l'
empire français et l'alignement de ces
pensions sur celles des combattants
métropole est un ancien combattant
français originaire de la métropole ou
de l' empire
vous êtes l'élite de la nation votez
pour celui qui veut que vous ayez droit
à la considération voter pour celui qui
défend vos droits légitimes voter pour
jean marie le pen
merci roger holeindre sylla médias oui
vous êtes pupille de la nation vous êtes
originaire d'algérie et vous êtes
conseiller régional d'île de france
alors pourquoi soutenez-vous jean marie
le pen
je suis fils du grand serviteur de la
france qui était moins médias oui
premier adjoint au maire de sidi bel
abbès conseiller général sénateur
durrani officier de la légion d'honneur
titulaire de la croix de la valeur
militaire tué pour avoir défendu les
valeurs éternelles de la france je suis
venu vous dire que j'ai choisi de
soutenir jean marie le pen qui est pour
moi comme un autre père car il m'a
montré les qualités que je n'ai trouvé
chez aucun autre homme politique
son exigence de vérité lui vaut souvent
se voir reprocher sa lucidité sur des
questions que d'autres prêtent par le
mensonge il faut voter jan map pour jean
marie le pen sans se laisser abuser par
la propagande de ceux qui déforme ciel
dans cette thèse en l'accusant de
racisme
jean marie le pen est loin de cela le
seul homme politique à n'avoir jamais
menti aux français et à traiter leurs
problèmes sans complaisance ni compromis
je recommande donc à tous et en
particulier à tous mes compatriotes
musulmans ne pas d'écouter les
faussaires de la politique et de voter
pour jean marie le pen
un homme probe qui à cette franchise que
dans toute démocratie
chaque citoyen est en droit d'attendre
de ses dirigeants
monsieur oui merci jean michel dubois
bonsoir vous êtes chef d'entreprise vous
êtes élus consulaires et co auteur d'un
livre sur l'emploi alors qu'est ce qui
vous rapproche de jean-marie le pen
vous savez promouvoir toutes les
libertés indispensable à l'adaptation
des entreprises face aux mutations
économiques accéléré
telles sont les ambitions des chefs
d'entreprise partant du principe que
c'est l'entreprise qui crée l'emploi
nous responsables de petites et moyennes
entreprises nous n'avons qu'une seule
alternative à la prochaine élection
présidentielle
voter pour un homme d'entreprise voter
pour jean marie le pen
face au candidat fonctionnaires jean
marie le pen lui est un homme
d'entreprise
il a créé et dirigé son entreprise
pendant trente ans il est le seul à
connaître les problèmes des pme pmi pour
les avoir lui-même vécu voter pour jean
marie le pen car il propose la
déréglementation administrative et la
suppression de l'intervention de l'état
dans la vie courante des entreprises la
suppression immédiate de la taxe
professionnelle la réduction
constitutionnel des prélèvements
obligatoires de 45 à 35 % la promotion
des produits fabriqués en france par
rapport à ceux provenant de pays à bas
salaires
la priorité des aides aux seules
entreprises françaises et pour les
artisans que si vous souhaitez jean
michel dubois jean marie le pen est le
seul candidat à défendre les petits
commerces de proximité indispensable
pour la vie sociologique dans les villes
les grandes surfaces qui à moyen terme
condamne les petits commerces ne doivent
plus être protégés
il faut immédiatement stoppé leur
implantation genre marie le pen en est
d'accord il le fera vous les artisans
vous devez résister à la pression des
machines super automatisé continuer à
faire de la qualité
ce sera notre patrimoine de demain et
surtout cela fierté de nos enfants et de
nos petits enfants le 23 avril pour le
plein emploi pour une france forte et
indépendante vote et jean marie le pen
merci jean michel dubois avant de
retrouver jean marie le pen pour les
cinq dernières minutes de l'émission je
vous propose d'écouter d'autres
témoignages que nous avons enregistré
claude autant-lara cinéaste français
personnellement je suis la durée le mans
pour une liberté d'expression totale
n'existe absolument plus dans le domaine
de la culture et dans bien d'autres
d'ailleurs de l'époque où nous vivons
il y as chez les créateurs partout quel
qu'il soit une espèce de retenue
d'autocensure qui se font eux mêmes et
qui est très paralysante pour les voix
de l'esprit avec jean-marie vue était
vraiment rassuré et c'est pour ça que je
me suis rallié à lui que j'allais à
strasbourg ou alors là j'ai été malmené
au bout de je n'ai même pas de
m'exprimer et de la même là bas tu en
tant que président du parc du parlement
européen
j'ai été mis dans un coin et on a brillé
de notaire jean errecart vanhoof
président fondateur de l'association des
polytron fusée membres du comité de
soutien de jean marie le pen
nous avons été les premiers à dénoncer
le scandale du sang contaminé et victime
avait au moins un droit huguette fatna
présidente du comité de soutien dom-tom
de jean-marie le pen
les compatriotes de l'outre-mer français
droit de faire comme moi faire confiance
à jean marie le pen
andré giresse magistrat ancien président
de la cour d'assises de paris contre la
concussion pour la sécurité première des
libertés
pour rappel le mans et devra être
appliquée pour les crimes de plus grave
pour la justice ne soit plus prêter en
piscine is ce soutien jean baril on en
rit rit sous inspecteur général des
finances ancien député membre de la
résistance des corps et à ce titre de
légion d'honneur
la croix de guerre des médailles la
résistance clé de leçon à recevoir de
personne
j'ai l'habitude de prendre mes
responsabilités et de choisir dans
l'intérêt de la france et des français
c'est pourquoi je soutiens de jean marie
le pen colonel jean jacques girardin
commandant de la garde présidentielle de
l'elysée de 1975 à 1981
j'ai eu l'occasion de côtoyer presque
tous les chefs d'état du monde en
assurant leur sécurité en le rendant les
zones
je peux affirmer que jean marie le pen a
l'envergure d'un président de la
république jean marie le pen en
conclusion de cette campagne on constate
que les français qu'ils vous soutiennent
ou viennent de toutes les catégories
sociales et professionnelles alors
j'aimerais savoir quoi ça tient
je crois que là c'est normal l'élection
présidentielle doit désigner un homme et
une politique comme en fait j'ai une
expérience relativement vaste je suis né
dans une famille très modeste
j'ai ité travailleurs manuels j'ai été
chef d'entreprise j'ai été hommes
politiques d'une part et d'autre part
mon programme on recouvre à peu près
toutes les préoccupations des françaises
et des français et singulièrement de
ceux évidemment qui sont les plus
malheureux tous les candidats ont leur
programme leurs catalogues de promesses
et les françaises jouent pas sont assez
sceptiques alors j'aimerais quand même
avoir votre notre analyse la situation
économique et en particulier de l'emploi
du chômage des dix ans la vérité le
bilan de la vème république est un bilan
de faillite et je vais apporter si vous
voulez bien les pièces du dossier car je
lisais avec moi je voulais bien
considérer regardez ce la croissance de
l'économie
1958 6% 1994 - 2 2 pouces ont regardé le
problème des naissances en notant que
nous sommes arrivés à sept cent mille
naissances ce qui est catastrophique
nous ne renouvelons pas les générations
nombre d'agriculteurs
nous venons de 6 millions et nous sommes
maintenant à un million et l'europe veut
faire descendre se chiffrent à 200 ou
300 milles voilà la valeur du franc par
rapport au mark
elle n'a cessé de se dégrader il vous
savez bien qu'elles diminuent tous les
jours autrement dit tous les courbes qui
devrait monter des sens maintenant je
vais vous montrer les courbes qui
devrait descendre et qui monte
voilà le chômage en notant que 3400 3
millions 400 mille c'est le chiffre
officiel est que le chiffre réel est en
fait de 6 millions de personnes sans
emploi
regardez le trafic de drogue c'est
vertigineux assez les interpellations
couvrir le dernier rapport indique que
par exemple à titre d'information 40
noeuds
pour cent des gens qui ont été arrêtés
l'an dernier sont des étrangers
voilà encore la montée les crimes des
délits 4 million de crimes et délits en
progression constante ce qui explique le
sentiment d'insécurité des français
voilà les prélèvements obligatoires
c'est à dire la somme des impôts et
aider des prélèvements sociaux au niveau
44 et demi pour cent monsieur l'aurait
qui est un grand fiscaliste affirme même
que c'est 55 % de la richesse nationale
et voilà la dette de l'état vertigineuse
elle nous coûte 200 milliards par an et
monsieur balladur vient de l'augmenter
en deux ans deux mille milliards
il me semble qu'après cela il doit être
assez difficile aux électrices et aux
électeurs français de choisir un des
trois candidats arrivés en tête car ces
trois candidats ont une responsabilité
égale dans la manière dont la france a
été gérée depuis plusieurs décennies
d'accord pour le bilan mais quelle
solution crédible à porter vous écoutez
moi j'apporte toute une série de
solutions
et d'abord la solution nationale par
rapport aux solutions euro mondialiste
qui sont celles de mes concurrents et
qui amène la france à la ruine
j'échappe la porte les pièces du dossier
c'est la préférence nationale
c'est la fin de l'immigration et le
retour grande partie des immigrés dans
leur pays c'est la diminution des impôts
et des charges
c'est je dirais la propreté politique la
fin de la corruption
c'est aussi la faim de l'insécurité par
des mesures que j'ai exposé à de
nombreuses reprises hélas malgré le peu
de temps que j'ai eus puisque j'ai eu
cinq heures de télévision
vous savez bien quand mes concurrents
ont eu 25 heures demandez moi aussi
d'être très très court alors juste une
question de prix gates en verre il a
beau ce qui revient à l'ordre du jour
est également la prolifération de l'armé
nucléaire
qu'est ce que nous pensons et côté il ya
trois ans quand a commencé la perte de
yougoslavie j'ai dit que la france
n'avait rien à faire dans ce conflit
balayons d'abord devant notre porte
avant de balayer devant celle des autres
1 la puissance nucléaire française est
avec les dom-tom né des deux raisons de
la puissance internationale de la france
si nous perdons cet atout là nous ne
serons plus grandes puissances c'est
pour ça qu'il faut faire des essais
nucléaires
r au plus tôt alors maintenant un peu de
politique
vous souhaitez vous dites que vous serez
au deuxième tour comment est ce possible
je le crois parce que d'abord je pense
que les français ont été trompés par les
sondages et que cette semaine va leur
permettre de se reprendre de regarder et
de comparer et de se méfier des
promesses dont ils savent qu'elles sont
fallacieuses
je crois que je peux être deuxième tour
je crois que le jospin et balladur sont
en difficulté et même si chirac est en
tête je pense que je peux passer devant
le deuxième et de troisième
il faut pour cela que les français se
mobilisent de quelques partis ou de
quelque obédience qu'il soit il faut
qu'ils portent leurs voix sur celui qui
représente une protestation alors tout à
une fin il va falloir conclure pour
conclure il ajouté pour conclure je
crois que le choix qui est à faire dans
cette présidentielle
c'est un choix entre la france la durée
de la france la défense des français
d'abord plutôt que le choix d'une
solution euro mondialiste qui va nous
amener à la catastrophe et au désastre
français d'abord
français toujours
français passionnément
[Musique]